and I had two calls yesterday one from a
county attorney Kentucky and one from a
county attorney in Tennessee they were
they were Republican obviously that both
states are heavily Republican they want
to know if there are ways they can go
after the bidens now and they've opened
up a can of worms they've sent
precedents now that we can't go back on
and now we're going to see a Judicial
System that's already bogged down with
with doing what they're supposed to do
and that's going after real criminals
now what jurisdiction would these DA's
have to indict Biden there of course
isn't any because the crime would have
had to take place in one of those two
states remember Donald Trump's hush
money payment that took place in New
York City and where are the charges
coming from about this you guessed it
New York City